so Marvel just announced that there is
going to be a new Avengers infinity war
trailer coming out tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on all things infinity war and to
hear my review about the trailer
tomorrow if you caught the video I did
on the photos that Entertainment Weekly
released you know that we saw a clip of
Thanos throwing a moon at comic-con in
San Diego not too long ago they showed a
trailer for Avengers infinity war that
has not been released to the public yet
in that trailer we actually see a a nose
grabbing and throwing the moon this is
more than likely us receiving this
trailer that they showed at San Diego
comic-con so what can we expect to see
in this trailer tomorrow besides Stannis
throwing the moon which is obviously
super exciting to be able to see we're
gonna see the guardians of the galaxy
pick up Thor and take him aboard their
ship this is the scene that we currently
have in the trailers where he says who
the hell are you guys and then it shows
the guardians of the galaxy I think
we're gonna see a little more insight on
Loki as well we know that he's going to
betray Thor because he was originally
working for Thanos in the beginning and
is more than likely we'll see him giving
Thanos the space stone we may get a
better look at spider-man's iron spider
suit as well we've seen a little bit
about it so far but maybe this new
trailer will give us an extended look at
it and maybe some of its abilities one
thing I think we'll get a more in-depth
look at is Titan Thanos his homeworld on
Titan I think we're gonna see some
Avengers but not all of them try to
fight Thanos and stop him here we'll get
just a tiny glimpse of how powerful that
house really is whether it's punching
Iron Man in the head and knocking him to
the ground or finally getting that scene
where he grabs the moon out of orbit and
throws it at the Avengers we're going to
see a lot more fight scenes going on
whether some of the Avengers breaking
out of the prison they're in whether
it's fighting in Wakanda fighting on
Titan or anywhere else I think we'll get
a glimpse of a lot more fight scenes
that are gonna be in the movie also
since it's more than likely the last
trailer we get before the movie comes
out I think it'll be a lot more intense
and dramatic maybe you'll even give us a
glimpse into someone about to die
because unfortunately we know that some
Avengers will die in the movie what do
you think we'll see and what do you hope
to see in the trailer that's released
tomorrow let me know in the comments
below and be sure to drop a like and
please subscribe to my channel to stay
today on Avengers infinity war Marvel
and all things superhero thank you so
much for watching and have a great day